[Music]
so I'm poor young for those who don't
know me I am the go-to-market director
for SCP at Google cloud but a history
fits the challenge of a CP world's kind
of a it's a small family and sometimes
these things are like family reunions
but there are a few feces in the crowd
that I don't know so to give you the
history I started out my ACB career with
Hewlett Packard I was on board with HP
actually launched for a pre-release of
r3 and got sent on assignment to Val
Dorf to help make it run on HP 9000
pa-risc machine this is a long time ago
released 0.9 if you go that far back and
bought it deployed it ran it at HP for
eight years and then SCP said hey why
don't you come work for us and 20 years
later I was still working for SCP so the
plan was never really to spend 20 years
of their see beads just that's how it
all worked out so various different
roles the last seven years of which I
was part of the management team for
Chanukah lovely and in the last two and
a half I got asked to take on a little
site project which was worked with the
cloud providers on a CP in cloud and the
more I did that the more it became
obvious the world was going to change
and going to change in a very
significant way and you never want to be
on the wrong side to change so Google
came along a year ago and asked me to
join and take on the go-to market for
SCP and it's fastly actually LinkedIn on
Monday auto-generated a message that
said congratulate Paul on being one year
at Google cloud so all week I've just
been getting hammered with emails some
people were saying also hitting the
congrats button that's good that's nice
like what Congrats were surviving
apparently I don't know one year is a
particularly significant thing to do I
think more significant is the is what
we've done in that year right and so
we'll get into the details of the
specifics but basically nine months ago
we launched the four terabyte Hana
servers that made us that was
significantly entering this market and
from where we were then to where we are
now there's no comparison we are we are
charging forwards
I'll tell you a separate story really
quickly before being the content which
is sapphire last year which was me I I
was walking to sapphire with one of our
office of the CTO team and as we were
kind of the last day of sapphire we're
going out in the escalator and the he
said turned to me and he said how do you
think we're going to win in this market
and I said what do you mean and he said
we'll look you know I like it iBM is
beatta in this market for two years you
know they've had some of these customers
for 40 years
HP's been in this market there's to be
market for 28 years
you know we kind of been in this market
for 16 minutes so far like how are we
actually gonna win in this market and my
answer to him at the time was we're not
gonna win in this market but first of
all I was here 20 years ago right I'm
well aware of the history and I'm gonna
tell you right now we're not gonna win
in this market what we're gonna do is
we're gonna change this market and we're
gonna make everyone else compete with us
do which afterwards long time after she
said I looked at you and I thought is he
insane at the point where I said that
I'm not insane this is a market that
needs to change this is a market where
the customers want things that they've
never got they didn't get from the
original providers they didn't get from
the cloud providers and we're gonna
deliver it to them as part of Google so
just take that context in mind as we go
through the rest of this conversation
right so first up imagine many of you
are customers but imagine you are a
customer and some other things for those
of you this is theater of the mind
people for those of you who are
customers you are for the rest of you
who are Google employees partners
everything else just put yourself in the
mindset of an SCP customer right and I
thought you want to do this internally I
would say yeah this is not intended to
be ego centric but the a lot of them
kind of look like me frankly right
they've been doing this for 30 years
they you know they they're fundamentally
the bottom line and all of this they're
fundamentally paid not to take risk
right
ACP runs their business if a CP is down
their business doesn't run we'll talk
about this a little bit later on
but I mean it's funny we wrote a slider
while ago on on just minimizing downtime
and we had a life science customer who
came to us and the team was debating the
cost of the infrastructure and the cost
of everything else and as we went
through it
the CIO said wait wait wait I heard some
stuff in this conversation about who you
could minimize downtime they said we'll
look you know and if you're in life
sciences right now either pharmaceutical
or a medical device what happens is
they're you know fundamentally the way
the law is written at this time that if
SCP isn't up and running you can't
manufacture right if you're in
pharmaceutical should require to
identify for every pill you manufacture
all the source ingredients really came
from which batches they came from the
recipe that was used to make them the
production couldn't wait to use them
right it basically isn't online you
can't record any of that stuff
everything stops if you're in the
medical device if you're making
pacemakers you're required to identify
you know all the components all the
wires the batteries so if something goes
wrong the FDA literally you had real to
have been effectively under an hour come
back in and tell them every patient in
the planet that has that battery
embedded inside their body right
if STP isn't online the world stops
right don't time is a huge thing and his
example was you know we're do being
costs were doing everything else no one
ever comes to me and talks about
lowering my cost and increasing my
uptime right they tell me how I can
spend a lot more to get out of time
they don't tell me how I can do both at
the same time it's like just to give you
a perspective it's and in their case to
the ten billion dollar your
manufacturers answer is ACP is down we
have to stop all the manufacturing
plants and it cost us a million dollars
an hour to shut down the manufacturing
plants and we fill that serial number
time since and what's what's becoming
hilarious about this is the need for
other customers to then one up that
story and so we retool after our story
recently a customer said is 10 million
dollars an hour for us
we're 10 million dollars an hour when
ACP is down right and so I get it right
I get the challenge I've run these
systems myself ultimately you're you
know the objective is to keep it running
because it's what runs the business and
if the business isn't running you're not
making money and a lot of your friends
and colleagues and stock investments
they're also dependent on that and so
the point where you see let's move to
the cloud you can perceive that as risk
candidly the point where you say hey
let's move to Google cloud right there
the guys have been in business in this
business 60 minutes is that really a
risk right and how do we handle that and
so it's not right we've had a very
talented group of people who know a lot
about SVP who we've come here we're
doing a lot in engineering that a lot
date you want in order to make that a
very safe bet
but equally I've said this a couple of
times through our presentations we've
made so far I'm also brutally aware that
the number one sales force for SCP is
SCP zone customers right
generally SCPs customers buy from suv's
customers one of them does something
they prove it works and then they go
tell all their friends and they carry
through and so in that context I'll also
just stop pause at the start of this
here to say I'm incredibly grateful for
the customers who who've come to us over
the course of the past nine months and
we made a very deliberate strategy of
going to market and saying look I you
know we can start small and get small
customers and try to build over the
course of many many years but the
reality of this market again is you
start a small your small customer you go
to the next one they say well yeah but
I'm bigger than them will it work for me
and so we do the other side you've seen
who are the biggest guys that we can get
right who are the biggest customers we
can get so normal question that we're
serious about the enterprise and the one
question this works normal question we
can do scale and boy did the customer
step up so I've already been on stage
with McKesson you know obviously
McKesson is fortune 6 the literally
healthcare doesn't work if McKesson
isn't working we've you know within the
past week the ever notice that we have
their contract for their SCP
environments among other things we've
had so we have a metro on stage they're
formally the number two retailer in
Europe Home Depot's done speeches to our
solution later the number three retailer
in the US that's just a small snapshot
of the customers you see a lot more
names come out over the over the period
here for the big huge customers that
have come to Google cloud along the way
and so that's an incredible foundation
to go from and hopefully we've set the
foundation in place for everyone to
adopt that said they just come back -
yeah yeah all great bear mr.
talking-head what are you gonna do for
me
so let's talk about you so three key
fundamentals that we're trying to get to
here in ACP on Google cloud number one
of which is simplified deployments two
words water complexity behind that right
but I mean what we'll go through some of
the details but what I'll tell you right
now is for almost everybody else in this
business in the large-scale environment
so Anthon about four terabytes it's a
twelve week lead time to deliver a
server to you right now minimum for our
entire fleet globally all of our SCP
equipment is 30 second provisioning 30
seconds after you click console you have
an SCP server buried ready to go at any
scale right that just on that there's a
simplification part to that but there's
also it just unlocks potential in a huge
way right so instead of saying hey I'm a
really great idea boss I'm saying yeah
put a proposal together maybe we'll have
some spare time a year from now when
we've got a server that's not in use and
you can play with it you can put a
server in 30 seconds and if it makes if
it makes sense that that's good for your
business you can roll forward from there
no one else is close to that I'm reduced
risk becomes a big deal we've talked
about some of this one would have been
the details but again diamond type
matters any huge way here right
availability matters in a huge way
something that we set out to engineer
into our SCP environments from the start
right this wasn't our let's just build
some boxes and let the customer manage
this there's a clear recognition from
our site that you know historically high
availability disaster recovery a really
big deal for customers especially dr is
really hard to do you tend to end up in
third party coolers you're never
entirely sure if it works if it doesn't
work huge amount of work from our site
to automate the deployment of that to
make it as secure as possible to make it
as reliable as possible so dr happens
just by default right and you don't have
to spend your time worrying about the
backend infrastructure and pain no
offense to the consultants in the room
but paying consultants to the wire all
that up it just comes over the box and
works right and then intelligence
becomes the last part I think this is
the other component where I think
they're really fascinating part of
Google as a company and Google cloud and
Google cloud I should see and the bigger
Google and what we can do for you is
this
isn't just hey we do boxes right you
know the bigger google has a huge amount
of assets when you get into the work
we're doing with bigquery and alysha to
bigquery when you look at the data sets
that we have so the close for marketing
data set where if you're a retailer or a
consumer packaged goods company or an
airline or anyone else the data we have
that it's anonymized but tells you
what's going on and you're advertising
what's going on your target markets the
ability to join that all the way through
and get a better algorithm and better
decision-making and better results puts
us apart from the competition right this
is not just how many boxes do you want
we haven't we have a I think frankly the
McKesson guys put it best which is you
know we just don't view this as being a
move to the cloud we view this as a
future architecture for our business I'm
not sure you say that about the other
guys in this business right that's where
we are
so with that saying let's get going on
the the the meat of this so this slide
deck or this particular slide star Eid
goddess for showing actually a partner
day next San Francisco nine months ago
and all the players have a different way
of projecting their capabilities they're
basically to give you a color scheme of
what's going on here if it's at the time
basically from the the middle know from
the last dark green no to the left was
what was available so the right was what
was promised in the future right so
there's a six terabytes seventh hour by
twelve terabyte and an 18 terabyte box
on that at the time there was basically
here's where we are now before here's
where we'll be in the future right and
so a next San Francisco last year in
June we stood up and said we have a for
now we will have six actually
technically a seven wasn't on the list
at that point we will have a six a 12
and an 18 come in in 2019 and at the
time we took a lot of questions we took
a lot of questions because first of all
no one has ever done these are all
virtual machines and no one has ever
done a virtual machine bigger than 6
terabytes before for Hana so the first
question was how are you gonna do a 12
to IBM how are you gonna do an 18
terabyte DM right is that even possible
I'll let you know a secret by the way we
had a motor running already right where
I I with as a group ourselves in the
engineering team had to basically prove
this would work before we were allowed
to pre-announce it but equally
knowing that and knowing that that only
knows it coming to market that tells you
the amount of engineering testing work
we do to make sure these things are
solid so yeah we in earnest the twelve
in the eighteen then and several greater
12 and 18 terabytes servers a lot of
people came back and said are you really
gonna do that how is that even possible
is it even technically possible and the
short answer is yes because as announced
yesterday on new slide there you go we
have no need the 6 and the 12 available
in early access to customers so that
means they are already reacted or DC's
they are available to customers you
can't go into console right now and see
I want to talk to everybody because
we're still in the testing phase they're
in early access but if you come to your
rep and we pass the message to
engineering so you like to test one you
can have 6 or 12 terabytes server to
test right now they're available they
will become available to everyone
hopefully by the half point of the year
certified by SCP thereafter and
available for you to use at 30 second
provisioning globally so I'm not aware
of any of my competition where you can
go to them and say hey I want a 12
terabytes server and they'll say yeah
sure 30 seconds from now done right and
it's just to give you an example of
again where we want to this is an in
this is an operation that acts at scale
right there's to be customers acted huge
scale questions at the end but I'm I'm
not answering competitive kind of
questions simple answer questions at the
end so the where we get to run off track
quickly the again this just opens a
world of potential for you right that
context of I need a big server I have a
big server off we go
is unique and the bear was going to see
quickly is again where we're different
from that from all of our competition
frankly is o the rest of our competition
tends to build a single box certify it
prove it works and then says right now
go sell it and we'll build some as we
sell them we have built tested
engineered
Boyd huge capacity already so that when
it comes online customers are just able
to consume right we don't intend to come
after this market one box at a time for
the record I keep saying box 90 it's
going to slap me when I get on stage
because there are no boxes here this is
an entirely virtualized environment and
if you follow that graph there's an 18
terabytes server the foulest at the end
of the year all the same rules right and
so the first thing I does is that resets
the speed that you can operate SCP at
all right we'll talk about some
customers in a second I'm actually I'll
jump forward to one really quickly Tory
Burch I'm Tory Burch have done a couple
of speeches for us I mean great
customers there
so Tory brush basically did a Greenfield
deployment of S or Hana
beyond consulting is there partner for
the people client they could work with
Hitachi och SIA is there is there MSP
partner both of their tremendous job
love what I love with Tory Burch is
doing the fundamentally from Tory Burch
signing the contract to being live they
had a fully configured system in 16
weeks fully rolled out to all their
central office and all the retail stores
in six weeks after that and again put
that in context of most of my
competition will take 12 weeks to
deliver your server they had a server 30
seconds after they started right that
sort of stuff just completely adjusts
the thought process of how you run
projects right it's pay by the second I
said before if you were if you have an
idea you went to trial if you have
something you want to try out right now
the expensive bid is the hardware right
there's a giant big step involved in
getting the hardware together to trial
something inane expensive provision it
render by the second turn it off again
and this is a bit for the SUV
practitioners in the audience so this
isn't just hey we're one more place
where you can run s AP right this is not
a CP hosting right this is a completely
new operating paradigm where you can
restructure how you run projects and
apply that properly and it's incredibly
valuable and with that I'll just
highlight up as much as I said I don't
do care I'll clarify I
do specific comparisons with specific
competitors by name that's a rule what I
will do however is I'll give you a
comparison of other providers to us
right
so if I can't say there's other
providers if you want 12 terabytes
server from any other providers right
now you have to place an order it
typically takes 12 weeks and you have to
pay upfront for the server because it's
hosting by any other name it's not cloud
it's not elastic you are you are paying
them for the server for them to buy it
and deploy it and then rent it to you on
a fixed three or five year contract it's
hardware running in the cloud it's
hosting it's not cloud as I understand
it so here is my understanding having
done this job most of you don't actually
need that capacity right now right so
for the history of time the way it works
at SCP is when you want to deploy a new
environment you go to SCP quick sizer
and you put in all the details of what
you think will be the busiest hour of in
the next three years and with the most
number of users and the most of our
transactions and quick sizer comes back
and says to handle that hour you will
require this much hardware and you go by
that much hardware and you plug it in at
technically you don't buy that much
hardware what you then do is you go what
if I'm wrong so you add 10% and then a
plan goes what if he was wrong and he
had 10% you buy we more hardware than
you need in the hope that three years
from now you're right and I have a
question I've used that a lot of these
speeches so if you've heard it before
don't please don't cheat that I was
actually at the CX forum for a CPS
conference cause retailers and I from
the stage I said well two things number
one which does anyone in the audience
know quite quick sizer works on a
three-year timeline does anyone know why
ICP picked three years
I like the puzzled looks I'm again here
it's the question no one ever thought of
I'll tell you why because once again I
was there quick starter runs over three
years because hardware depreciates over
three years and the plan was build quick
sizer for three years so when we get to
year three and they discover it's too
small
it'll already have depreciated and so no
one's going to complain about the cost
there's no business reason for three
years there's no operational reason for
three years it was driven by hardware
depreciation but every
SCP customer has done it that way from
the beginning of time
why right and the same question asked in
the retail show was there was this is
late 2018 so my question was so if we
got to go three years to the future
let's go three years back anyone in the
audience know what the best-selling toy
was at Christmas of 2015
no I'll help you it was an Elsa doll
because enforcement was out and the fact
that none of us knows that means we
barely know anything about history so
anyone who wants to tell me what the
size they need in 2022
for their business please step up even
better anyone in the audience that knows
the best-selling toy in 2022 please come
talk to me because we're in the wrong
business
right there we should know by now the
future is not predictable right we've no
idea what's gonna happen with our
companies we have no idea how fast they
grow we have no idea who the emerged
with no idea by but we go and we do a
quick sizer and we take our best guess
that we were gonna be for three years
and then we try and fit the business
back to that my question always is so
you go you make your plan you're done
you you borrow your hardware it sets up
you're saying your fee your contract
with a cloud provider and the CEO walks
in the office goes we're going to do a
merger what do you do then
right Nasir is right all that cost off
in project costs for the merger it's not
efficient so so let's roll back let's
see I don't know how big you're gonna be
in three years let's say you don't know
how big you're gonna be the years let's
say we don't care right because we don't
care my answer when customers ask me
about this is look I only really care
about two questions on this slide number
one of which is tell me how big you are
right now and tell me you don't honestly
think that in the next two years you're
go off the top end of that chart as long
as those two things are true we have a
deal right so let's imagine that right
now you're rolling RS for your drawing
you're doing a solid ation should do and
everything else and you go to the other
guys and the other guys say hey you know
you need 12 terabytes three years from
now so I need you to say in a three year
contract
take your 12 terabyte system
peered up front and you'll be good right
that's the left side let's see you come
to Google cloud you see hey I need four
terabytes no and he eat in in next year
and I need 12 in the third year I could
do that
all I need you to do is say this is what
I need now and then as you grow you just
grow the consumption under vm you just
resize the VM upwards as you go and it
happens and you just pay me for what
you're using not what you'll need in
three years from now right I've taken
the risk out of this equation all you
need to do is pay me for what you need
right now that that dark blue box by the
way the difference in price for a 12
terabyte if you if you take a 12
terabyte commit from the other guys or
you come to me and you step up a for an
18 or 12 as you need it the savings that
dark blue box is five hundred and fifty
thousand dollars per server at list you
need four of them start with this is not
a small amount of money and applies
across anarkali there is a retailer I
won't name them but there is a large
retailer we're working with who is doing
exactly this right now instead of doing
a three-year sizing instead of doing a
year sizing well they've basically done
this size June July and they've
committed to the June July capacity they
need and for most of the year they run
June July capacity and then at Ober they
come here and say what does Christmas
look like this year and they come in and
effectively spot by capacity from us for
October for excite for November December
and the first half of January and then
they give it back to us suddenly resize
back to what do you think next year
looks like in capacity do the math in
your heads for how much money that saves
you right and so I'll go back to the
earlier statement
I left safar last year with a statement
which is we're not going to you know try
and compete in this business we're going
to change this business and we're gonna
make everyone else compete with us right
and it's been a long hard run I'm very
appreciative for everything was done but
as that six in that twelve commerce
online as the eating Commons online in
their end of the year the world's gonna
change right candidly my biggest problem
I have right now is we still get rfp's
in from consultants who've run quick
sizer and said because this the years
from now like no they don't want this
the year from now
you want a minimum cost operation that
flexes with them as they go they just
didn't know it was possible right
quietly the help I need from you guys as
customers and partners is I need you to
you know recognize the point where you
come in for a bid to tell the whoever's
doing the bid for you that you want this
flexibility right we've built that we've
built the foundation ultimately by the
way you guys will change the world
right we're just giving you the ability
to do it this is what we're know Nancy
thinks Portland's like he's in seen but
only reduced risk sort of a reduced risk
so when you get to operation with Google
cloud so great were cheaper or
everything else is it enough well again
I've lived this life right i-i've lived
this like myself where well I'm old
enough that I've lived this life when I
used to carry a pager a real pager I get
page and say the systems are down and I
it's the toiletries I work for HP I used
to carry a dial in terminal in the trunk
of my car and have to find an acoustic
coupler and plug it in that beats me for
age but I've lived this life right none
of us want none of us want to deal with
the hey the systems not working right
none of us want to deal with the
argument where the where the CFO says I
know we have security patches but we've
got to get the financial results out why
do you have to make that compromise at
all right and so one of the key things
that we work at an engineering is okay
if we're going to go entirely vmb so if
we're going to go for a 100 percent vm
infrastructure what can we do bad right
there has to be other capabilities and
so I'll give you one right now so we
have a tool called live migration it
applies to all of our fleet by the way
but it really works well for Hana and
for further STP applications
so what live migration does is you are
running your SCP environment application
servers database servers everything else
on a set of VMs right and what happens
right now is so let's take meltdown
spectra one of the big security patches
comes along every other provider on the
planet what happens is you get an email
that on Patch Tuesday the basis says hey
there is a major security vulnerability
all your machines have to be patched
within 72 hours this is Tuesday I'm not
aware of a single happy customer in the
world who
schedules don't aim Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday or Friday right but you don't
have an option because you have 72 hours
and that's what you've got to do see now
to take an unscheduled outage I mean or
do the patch know what a lot of other
guys will see well we have automatic
patching yeah you do but you gotta shut
the system down and then on reboot or
our nightly patchi's and you're gonna
take an outage it doesn't count as
notice really purposes but ICP ain't
running so as far as you're concerned
you're out right why does that have to
happen we do a live migration is
something very different I'm at the
point where we have a past security
patch just ready to go and because we're
entirely the N based in the RAC the same
record right close to where your s AP
environment is running a second VM will
start up exactly the same size and shape
as the current VM that you're running
you will get pre patch for security and
then a processor run that will sync the
contents of memory CPU and disk from the
server you're currently running on to
the new server that's been patched while
it continues to run ASAP continues to
run completely systems are aware the
users are really unaware that it is
being replicated as it goes and at
completion when we achieve sync the
network will take a millisecond pause
basically so low the original server you
were running on to drop out the new
server to take over the data will start
flowing into it and with zero downtime
and an imperceptible network pause you
will be fully patched with no downtime
right across your entire SCP fleet
across your entire fleet everything you
run so do the math right every time you
need a security patch you don't need to
do a security patch we handle all for
you and the really cool part on all this
is as much as I say everybody else
emails you on Tuesday to tell you you
need to down your systems and then you
have to go in a kiosk mode to manage
that and shut it down
we don't email you on Tuesday if the
flag is set on the hypervisor we pre
patch this before the security alert
goes out it happens completely
automatically you can turn it off by the
way if you want to know what
turn it all the way off but you can
actually turn it off and say I would
like to choose the point in time when it
happens over the course of the next 72
hours nobody does but you can if you
don't believe this by the way 20 we had
a customer said well this all sounds too
good to be true and so we actually
racked them a system with primary and eg
and process one course estudiar in
London all running weather an export
system running on top of it and we said
I've had it do what you want and when
the law clock shows is seven times in
the first hour we push test live
migration or put in transactions in and
an hour later they called us and said
hey this thing really works like yeah we
knew but you had to prove it to yourself
and that's okay right you can test it
yourself you can provision a server
deploy it hit the button it'll work
and again just do that math and that's
politely I will say one of the things
we've been working on today is not the
day to go through all our box of tricks
but there's a lot more tricks to come
right all of which are focused on the
life of an SCP customer and in getting
rid of all the things they care about
right sizing down time all of that stuff
we've built an environment where I can
deal with those problems I mean that no
one's done it before
we talked about this already but again
you know 10 billion dollar manufacturer
it's a million dollars per hour and lost
revenue three hours basically because
it's not just shutting down a single
server and rebooting it right you have
to shut down the entire cluster all the
supporting GRC GTS everything else you
have to patch them all you have to
reboot them all in the correct sequence
it's a huge amount of time it's the RS
every ten the shutdown is three million
dollars every time there's an outage -
$0 you don't have to do too many of the
risk before frankly I've built you in
revenue way more than my entire contract
costs right the game is about to change
with that I'll also give a quick
high-five to Intel octane one of the
bigger challenges is that you know it
varies depending on customer no chipset
but in general you know one terabyte per
terabyte of Hana on reboot it takes
about an hour per terabyte to get back
to full capacity and operational run so
if you run a one terabyte Hana that's
problem right if you're running up 4
terabyte Hana
you're looking at about three hours
previously 45 minutes to recovery you're
looking at three hours of either non
performance or decreased performance if
you're running a big server 12 or an 18
terabytes server lab that number becomes
a significant encumbrance to you right
that the the the reboot time becomes the
vastly biggest part of this problem and
so one of things we've been doing with
Intel is deploying our teen in that by
the way is that seven terabyte box
that's sitting on that chart right now
which is the it's the first release of a
cascade leak server it's the first
release of an opt-in server and by the
way it was also the first VM bigger than
seven but bigger than six terabytes
available in market and it's opt-in
beast so what happens with the obtain
chips is they are non-volatile Ram so
without getting into some of the
specifics that I'm not allotted to
scores right now a significant
percentage of your data is actually in
non-volatile Ram
and so when Hana shuts down and restarts
or hypervisor understands where you were
it reallocates you the same non-volatile
Ram you had before that already has your
data in it it's just going to populate
the little bit of data that is the
softest changing most frequently and
you're fully operational again and so
instead of taking three eras above age
you're taking 15 minutes of outage right
so that's futures we're all through the
engineering but we've public with Intel
about the work we've been doing but you
know again huge impact right there are
we're working to minimize the number of
events and the amount of time that you
would have to actually take an s-u-v
server down but but there will always
exist times when you have to and so to
the extent we can sort reboot reboot
matters right reboot cost you money and
I can deal with that as it goes huge
deal and like I said much more to come
as we go forwards and just I'll also
pause a second and say that seventh
irate server just to show how far Google
has come and because I get the question
a lot from stbb well but why did you
choose to go to Google and the quick
answer is the engineering here is just
insane right the engineering is insane
to give you a point in time again last
June we launched a 4 terabyte server
a week after Microsoft launched theirs
a year after I was homeless there's six
months later we launched the first
obtain server for the first caste League
server the first VM that's ever been
built over six terabytes for Hana
there's a there's just a data point for
you on the commitment we're making to
the SCP space and the speed we are
changing this space at right we've just
launched the largest vm available in
market ever for Hana we're only just
getting started
we're only nine months in wait till you
see what follows and the other part I'll
quickly hi to you is the the you know we
build on top of everything that is
Google Cloud right it's an interesting
one because I also am a long-term part
of the conversation you get with SCP and
s to be customers is okay well how close
are you to me right so how close are
your data centers to me and frankly a
lot of all providers will say well I'm
really close to you I was a data center
so I'm really close to you again I ran a
global ICP system I think a lot of you
in the audience do as well I don't think
it's necessarily how close am I to you
because you is a lot of users who are
spread all over the world and it's how
fast can you get data to them right well
you're looking at is the Google cloud
network there is actually a if you'd
imagine from the loop so that actually
is a world map hidden behind that that's
currently not projecting through there's
a you know classic world map the the
users on the East Africa's on the west
their Americas in the middle you can
tell from the names huge amounts of
capacity in this network so the dirac
cable that's going in between Virginia
and France we provide you some details
on last week back cable is ours probably
owned by us that all of this is wholly
owned the robbery by us and that direct
cable on its own is US owned by the
Google cloud and is 250 terabits per
second you can transfer the entire
contents of the Library of Congress from
Virginia to France three times a second
and that's just one of those cables
right so the same network that we run
YouTube on the same network we run Gmail
on all the capabilities that that has
know also running all your data
backwards and forwards it's one the
reasons why frankly we do so well in
retail is you know the retail guys are
like well I've got to get out to all the
retail stores and how do I handle it and
there's a simple question right which is
do your employees use Gmail and YouTube
in the store yes they do
where's performance like pretty good
seem network right and so politely I'll
say there is a difference here right
would you we have a significant data
center footprint globally right now but
I will politely argue that the answer is
not we have a little data center close
to you to run your SCP environment the
answer is do you have the partners I
need and do you have the network to
deliver it out to everywhere I need to
deliver to and oh yeah we have that
there's a whole separate conversation
about security we do security incredibly
well in this case we own data from
pretty much your doorstep almost your
doorstep all the way through the network
fully secure and hand no handoffs no
third parties
no hey you bring your data to us it's
all managed there is a whole separate
conversation about what we do in that
space Metro EMC is you say I'm going to
come back to this so last one really
quickly I actually know there's a site
that's missing here but I'll talk to it
really quickly
just to give you a secondary concept
about what goes on with VMs and how we
manage risk with nobody handle structure
so when I said to you earlier is well
let's say you need a 12 right and we
only for now and then you need 80 12 and
you go into interesting use case I'll
give you a different scenario let's say
your natural so Metro has they will
publicly admit to over a hundred SCP
systems they're consolidated into a
single escort system and every time we
do this someone in the audience says
wait they have a hundred like dev and QA
and production no they have a hundred
standalone ERP production systems over a
hundred and because every division was
they operate in 25 countries therefore
live ERP is per country and because
every division was allowed to stand up
their own system in their own country
and the carbon objective is to get back
to one s for system right so the course
of a number of years we're going to do
that what makes us interesting and
fascinating in this space again with
what we're doing with virtual machines
is what everyone else would do is say
well three years from now you're going
to need our twelve terabyte
but by the way we're gonna need a
hundred 1 terabytes and 1/2 terabytes
never than else along the way so here's
the total package you have to buy out
front row and rack and handle when you
come to us the other part I didn't tell
you about earlier but when you come to
us and you say I need this amount of
capacity I actually don't need to know
what shape you need it in if you need 12
terabytes total I don't know that you I
don't need to know that you need 1/6 and
you know three twos don't care you're
buying 12 terabytes of capacity from me
you can shape them and reshape them as
you want through the course of the
project so if you're Metro and you're
starting you contract 12 terabytes from
us d1 you can write them as 24 half
terabyte Hana systems they - you can say
hey I don't like that
I'd like 6 1 terabytes 12 1/2 terabytes
great just reshape them doesn't hurt me
it doesn't cross hairs and then you come
along and say well we're starting like a
solid a what I want is a 4 and 8 ones
great for an 8 ones no I want six and
and three twos great a six two three
twos then you see what I want is a 12 I
have a 12 completely within your control
30 seconds to reshape you buy capacity
and you can restructure it any way you
want you can move it between QA and
production and dev and production you
can spin off test systems see if you
need additional capacity you can just
buy it from me by the second again risk
management cost management operational
never been done before
I'm not where anyone is going to match
us right but the potential that unlocks
in the SCP customer base and the ability
that gives you is quite incredible right
because we go back to that conversation
of why do I need to do a three-year
quick sizer I'm not buying a box right
what all I need to know is what capacity
do you need for this year and then what
capacity why dis requested you need for
next year you went over some bursting
capacity you can have bursting capacity
this isn't you know one more hosting
provider right this is a completely
right of the rules of how you run a CP
and we're right there where we've just
delivered the Harper class that does it
I'm going to spend a lot of time on
stages like this happen that converse
last part however you know all these
conversations I've done this aside from
year 13 now luckily LinkedIn doesn't
send a message saying young is when
you're a Google and he's very old the so
in any of these cell cycles right in any
of these processes that you go through
it's one thing to say hey Google's
really cool when it's safer it's more
risk averseness probably a bit cheaper
there's still a huge business risk that
goes with change right there's nothing
to do with technology usually retraining
upgrades testing there's all cost
someone else so there's got to be
something else on the other side and
what I think is fascinating here is
typically politically we relied on ACP
we rely on the partners rollin or soft
to provide this something else and what
I couldn't find that any of the other
providers was something else they were
quite happy to have you excited sell
your boxes and be done but I want to be
more than that to you I want to be a
much better partner so inside that we've
been working on this something else
right so in the case of bigquery and
bigquery is now pre integrated with SCP
right so you start Google bigquery you
can you improve data in the Google
bigquery you can join it to STP in real
time and do real-time analytics where
you have Google Data and SCP data so on
and so on you're gonna say yeah cool I
mean big queries are very very cool to
leave this it's just crushing the
industry right now however I was
crushing it I should say in the industry
however so what once again I will go
back to yeah but we have a set of data
sets that we can put into bigquery for
you right we will give you an anonymized
data set of your advertising as it is
running in Google that you can then link
back to the geographic locations where
you have imagery and you can do far
better planning than you used to
right and that puts me in a place where
I'm not just a technology provider for a
box store NSEP I'm an innovation partner
for you because I can deal with
analytics I can do with algorithm I can
apply machine learning to it there's a
lot of stuff I can now do right so if
their system says there's four in the
store and it hasn't sold any in the past
eight hours you can be pretty certain
all four of them have been stolen right
and you won't find that to your of the
shelf but you can actually see in the
data you can run the calculation
and the Challenger at home people Canada
is the supply lines are so long for some
of the remote stores that when you that
by the time you detect that it could be
a day from now when you detect that and
then when you Chris huge data sets this
whole point of so dated everyone else so
they need to take that it could be an
hour it could be a day from now and
they'll take another day to get it on
the next truck let's go in there so you
could be three days our stock on the
item and the answer is so a bunch of
that as well as moving BW in car and s4
into Google Cloud and run it live there
they also stood up bigquery and inside
big way they're running that velocity
algorithm and instead of running it once
a day which is what they were doing
before it runs every 15 minutes so every
50 minutes they get the likely suspects
from what is not in store and that way
instead of it being semi tours you start
to shrink it down to 24 hours before it
should plan - right the world is full of
those opportunities then again we've
tried to build the best environment we
can build to run SCP but we've also
integrated it through to a whole bunch
of other technology where this isn't
just hey you know what you had over
there is going to run over here this is
something much better I said a year ago
when I starting this every conversation
started with the we just wanted to do a
lift and shift we just want to do a
lifted shift I'm frankly I never
understood the concept of lift and shift
if it runs ok over there why we're here
where is the value and run it over here
by the time especially unless we were we
have to do all the testing and all the
rewriting of interfaces and everything
else right there's got to be something
more why and so again the something more
it is better uptime there's something
more is we more flexible pricing there's
something more is vastly improved
analytics right vastly improved business
outcomes and that's why we believe we're
a better partner for the long term last
thing however and is there to be you
guys know my favorite thing well you're
looking at as a mirror lifter shifter so
it's a basically it's a robot you
dispatches off where you say hey go over
there pick up that pallet bring it back
to me drop it so if I'm running pick
back operations in a DC or if I'm doing
store shelf packing basically you
dispatch it off it grabs us off to you
sticking boxes it does the walking for
you you came through very cool
one of things we look at is in in Google
world is okay how can we again extended
help our customers so what we had we
actually showed this at Tech Ed Las
Vegas last year with SCB we have one of
these walking around the floor we took
wanted to take it Barcelona as well
pre-integrated to sa P so robots are
hard right but time you deploy them
you've got to wire up the networks you
got to do the security you've got to do
all the programming your Chi over
through the mirror we don't make the
mirror but but we've embedded a Google
technology package in the mirror you
basically turn it on connect it to your
Wi-Fi and inside Google Cloud you
register the serial number and say hey I
own this mirror then it connects up
automatically to SCP and it's that
simple you just say hey I need you to go
over here grab this shelving unit and
bring it back to me and and base to be
commuter school go Google code can be
she's a robot robot gross grabs it and
come back huge deal to start with right
very cool what I'll tell you however is
something even cooler than that so I've
just missed it on timing here but when
the robot that I mean clearly 17 times a
minute this doofus parts of a forklift
in front of this robot when he parks
there the robot so it detects the
forklift in and walks around it when it
walks around it look at the front
there's two holes in the front of this
robot the tools are cameras it's
obviously it has to be able to see the
forklift as we will do a bunch of other
stuff but let me tell you what else it
does as it walks around it's able to see
the shelves right so it's when it clips
back around here it's able to see the
shelves it's able to see the Box season
it's gonna break them down into a set of
boxes and on those boxes it's going to
read the text it's going to read the
serial numbers it's going to read the
barcodes it's going to read the labels
and its gonna call back to SCP and it's
gonna say I am right now at this point
in store in we're hosting wherever I am
and I believe I have seven of these
sitting in this location is that what
you believe you have in inventory
continuous cyclical inventory drop it in
turn it on connected to the Wi-Fi
register it we are not just a provider
of boxes to host a CPU right
we are on a far different track we are
going to change this business I'll give
you one last thought on the robots by
the way let's see you're in an industry
like oil and gas or airplane whatever
where you have things that don't come in
boxes what happens then
well we demonstrated Barcelona and and
in Vegas is we're also integrated with a
3d scanner not a 3d scanner like on your
desktop on and on and so let's say you
have oil pumps when the oil pump comes
in the factory you sit it down you rule
the 3d scanner around and it will image
the 3d scanner the geometry patterns are
uploaded into the robot says the robots
go around and they see item on a shelf
and they basically say yeah you know
what I see that it can't find a text on
it can't find a serial number can't fit
a barcode so one of the geometry
analysis is about this long about this
time has this many bolts on the end of
it what do you think it is it's a pump
11:52 rev3 cool there's a pump 11:50 to
read free singing at this location in
the warehouse I'm not aware of anyone
else that's talking about doing all of
this stuff and again this is the total
package right where we are reinventing
how it runs massively making this
massive Lygia 30 second provision
globally making it much simpler to
consume much to produce too much way
higher uptime and then you add in the
analytics you I didn't bollocks there's
a ton of other stuff we're doing this is
a very different value proposition again
hopefully I've made that clear to you
and you understand that and today's
conversation I thank you for coming one
more time and politely ask you that you
know this is once again going to sound
strange but we're not here to be one
more hosting provider in the cloud we're
here to change how STP runs and I have a
lot of very talented people at Google
who endeavored to do it every day but
ultimately it's for you but it's also
with your assistants if you appreciate
this a we need the phone call when you
want to try it out but be you know I
need you to understand this message and
I need you to start setting that
criteria when when people come in and
say hey we need to go forwards the
answer is there's a different way to do
it
[Music]